[Musica]
quando mi hanno invitata a partecipare a
questo the licks la prima persona che è
apparsa davanti alla mia mente è una
bambina si chiama emma
eccola
essa mia luna per cinque anni e ora fa
prima media e mi è venuto in mente
questa immagine di emma in un intervallo
di fine prima elementare primaria per
gli addetti ai lavori
in una classe
che non era la sua incontra un materiale
misterioso molto colorato che le
permette di
scoprire il teorema di pitagora
ecco lo
è ma ha soltanto sette anni sa contare
fino a 25
conosce le forme geometriche ma in
maniera abbastanza approssimativa
e ma smonta questi tre quadrati di
diversi colori e poi arriva durante un
intervallo di giugno prima elementare e
mi dice maestra guarda questo quadrato
blu è composto da nove piccoli
quadratini e questo giallo da 16 piccoli
quadratini e quello rosso da 25 piccoli
quadratini quindi
quello blu più quello giallo è uguale a
quello rosso non sa parlare di cateti
potendo usare triangoli rettangoli ma
emma ha scoperto il teorema di pitagora
è stata pitagora ha messo le mani sul su
una scoperta e su e eureka
ho scoperto più tardi nonostante io
insegno 26 anni che nelle programmazioni
scolastiche il 3 ma di pitagora è
previsto tra la prima e la seconda media
da programma ed emma non è una bambina
precoce è soltanto una bambina che ha
avuto l'opportunità di accedere ad
un'esperienza di apprendimento
fuori dagli schemi cioè non prevista da
quello schema gigantesco che ad esempio
sono i programmi scolastici
e pensando ad emma
appunto avendo ricevuto questo invito
ho pensato che mi sarebbe piaciuto
parlare con voi di quattro coppie
diciamo così dicotomiche o falso
dicotomiche
che abitano la scuola il fare scuola ed
essere scuola
la prima di queste
coppie davvero dicotomiche ovvero di
concetti che tra loro credo siano uno
spartiacque importante
per chi insegna forse anche per chiedo
che anche per chi è genitore per chi ha
funzioni educative in vari modi e quella
scelta tra l'affermare che si fa ciò che
si fa perché si è sempre fatto così e
l'affermare che si fa ciò che si fa
perché ci si pongono delle domande ora
mi chiedo se il punto di domanda che va
dopo il punto esclamativo qua sul budget
abbia a che fare con questo con quello
che sta dicendo e
una domanda di fondo come i bambini
imparano
e dicembre tempo di open day
magari qualcuno di voi ne sta
frequentando
qualcuno perché deve andare iscrivere i
figli alla scuola materna sbaglia
primaria alle medie eccetera ci si
presenta in questi momenti come d'un
supermercato
vengono offerti servizi più vari ma se
qualcuno se qualcuno dal palco dal palco
sbagli nella platea
alzasse la mano per dire sì ma qual è la
vostra idea di come un bambino apprende
di come un ragazzo apprende di come
costruisce la casa della sua conoscenza
la casa di se stesso
probabilmente troveremo dall'altra parte
dei professionisti che su questo non si
sono forse soffermati tanto perché a
scuola è più facile che si faccia ciò
che si è sempre fatto ciò che fanno
tutti gli altri ciò che gli strumenti
più diffusi i libri di testo e altro
mettono nelle mani degli insegnanti ecco
il primo punto io credo davanti ai
bambini è scegliere tra il porsi la
domanda come un bambino apprende sapendo
che non lo sappiamo
sapendo che la risposta non ce l'abbiamo
e invece reiterare modelli che
sospendono appunto la domanda
la presentazione compariva il fatto che
io lavoro da alcuni anni in una scuola
con un indirizzo montessori faccio
formazione e coordino realtà che hanno
fatto questa stessa scelta
però credo che sia davvero rischioso
pensare che la risposta alla domanda
come impara un bambino stia in un metodo
credo che ancora qua ci sia una coppia
di concetti tra loro inconciliabili
se io scelgo un metodo scelgo di essere
un replicante scelgo di applicare una
ricetta in maniera appiattita
standardizzata senza guardare il bambino
don milani che stati più grande dei
maestri più di maria montessori non lo
dice ma nessuno
ai suoi ragazzi che pochi giorni prima
che lui morisse gli chiedevano priore
come possiamo replicare l'esperienza di
barbiana in altri luoghi quando saremo
più adulti e lui rispondeva fate scuola
come velo insegneranno i luoghi ei tempi
dove abita rete
non c'è peggior infedeltà che essere
fedeli a morto
soprattutto se poi il morto è un
innovatore un rivoluzionario visionario
quindi
scegliere
di seguire il manuale che troviamo in
libreria o il metodo qualunque sia con
qualsiasi bollino blu
vi possa persuadere è in realtà
scegliere di tradire il compito
educativo più grande che quello di saper
cercare farsi domande osservare i
bambini che sono il vero libro che
abbiamo davanti e scoprire come
costruiscono la loro casa perché la
ricerca educativa è quella che ci
permette di mette a disposizione dei
bambini un cantiere e dire loro i
muratori siete voi io ti mostri attrezzi
del mestiere ti allestisco appunto un
ambiente preparato perché tu possa
cemento cazzuola e tutto il resto
mettere insieme ciò che fa di te una
persona è una persona sapiente io ho da
costruire la mia di casa che nonostante
i 51 anni è ancora richiediamo anche la
molta manutenzione
e questo quindi ci aiuta a
sapere non saper in qualche modo da che
parte né vogliamo indirizzare il nostro
sguardo se guardare un metodo cioè
guardare noi stessi o se guardare i
bambini perché quando noi seguiamo
metodi bambini non riusciamo più a
vederli
e quindi maria montessori stessa diceva
nemmeno dovete nominarlo nemmeno dovete
pensare al concetto di metodo ma pensare
ai bambini che vi sono affidati come a
persone se la sono più spesso questo
termine in meno quello di infante in
qualche modo affinché possano diventare
indipendente uscire dagli schemi
gli occhi gli antichi pregiudizi
sull'educazione sono gli schemi del si è
sempre fatto così oa ma anche lo schema
del l'ha detto la montessori a pagina 52
della scoperta del bambino le ortodossie
nelle scienze umane e nelle scienze in
generale non aiutano
un altro terzo punto è invece una falsa
dicotomia questa sì noi tendiamo a
distinguere e anche forse gerarchizzare
l'educazione di educazione formale
quella che certifica la scuola i voti i
diplomi gli esami la scuola istituzione
quella appunto che fornisce
l'indicazione formale rispetto a quella
specie di ancella
supplettiva che l'educazione non formale
educazione non formale che
el'associazionismo io penso ho una
grande passione per lo scautismo da
madre è purtroppo non avendo praticato
nella mia gioventù e
così come associazionismo di altra
natura
lo sport la musica l'arte il teatro le
mostre musei i concerti
se io adesso avesse un po più di tempo
chiedere a ciascuno di voi di provare a
pensare quale quali sono le conoscenze
rispetto alle quali sente di sentirsi
maggiormente sicuro quali sono le vostre
conoscenze soldi delle vostre conoscenze
in quegli ambiti di conoscenze in cui vi
muovete con grande familiarità vi
sentite a vostro agio
in cui sapete di sapere e poi mi
piacerebbe chiedervi immagina di
scrivere su un altro foglietto dove
avete imparato quella cosa lì
qual è stata la situazione comunque
trevi ha permesso di costruire quella
conoscenza se lo facessi ma prendessimo
qui un grande un grande cartellone con
tutti quei posti scopriremmo che la gran
parte di voi
scriverebbe che quelle competenze quelle
vere competenze e conoscenze sono state
apprese fuori dalla scuola magari in un
viaggio magari in esperienze di altre
natura
allora credo che sia molto interessante
per la scuola raccogliere
questo spunto anziché considerarsi
appunto l'istituzione dove avviene il
vero percorso di formazione
riuscì a mutuare dalla dall'educazione
non formare l'educazione non formale i
modi i tempi gli spazi
l'idea che l'aula non sia il solo
ambiente di apprendimento lo è fino ad
una certa età ma poi qual è lo spazio in
cui si impara
può essere che io possa davvero come
insegnante predisporre per i ragazzi
adolescenti un cantiere che
effettivamente permette di mettere loro
uno sopra l'altro tutti i mattoni che
gli occorrono sappiamo che non è così
eppure la certificazione a cui la scuola
è chiamata tende a impedire
effettivamente di mutuare appunto da
educazione non formale
spunti di lavoro utili e soprattutto
quello che ci perdiamo e la possibilità
di
formare personalità integre e quando
dico integro non intendo integro
moralmente ma intendo integro cioè come
tutto unito tutto attaccato non
spezzettato come invece capita quando si
passa dall esperienza scolastica
al pomeriggio o al sabato la domenica in
cui si invece si compiono esperienze che
da un certo punto di vista sono
decisamente più formative ma che
litigano con i compiti ad esempio e qui
apriremo un grande capitolo che al
dodicesimo minuto non ci è concesso
aprire
e quindi anche i muse lettore naturali
sono dei luoghi fantastici apprendimento
e non c'è libro che sostituisca un
formicaio visto
dentro una teca e dire
analizzato con quello sguardo ii
l'ultimo
libertà e disciplina
provate a farvi apparire davanti
l'immagine di un bambino che voi
conosciate quindi un vero bambino
esistente libero e basta chi vi viene in
mente
e poi pensate ad un bambino disciplinato
potrai scommettere qualche soldo non ne
ho tanti che le due immagini sono
immagini diverse
la persona che avete pensato non è la
stessa persona
il bambino libero è un bambino insomma
un po non dico giamburrasca ma insomma
uno campo gli assomiglia
e il bambino disciplinato è un bambino
obbediente che fa quello che gli viene
detto maria montessori ci lascia questo
pensiero secondo me
straordinario straordinario
l'idea che l'essere disciplinati non sia
essere obbedienti
ma si sa essere padroni di se stessi
capaci di seguire delle regole di vita
laddove la vita la vita reale
necessiti di adeguarsi a mare vola
e io faccio fatica davvero a pensare a
qualcosa che desidero di più per i miei
figli ma per i miei alunni anche
che l'essere persone capaci di essere
padrone di se stesse di saper scegliere
sapersi collocare di saper pensare di
sapersi costruire di saper vedere dove i
mattoni traballano e dove hanno bisogno
di rinforzo
e credo che ne abbia molto bisogno anche
il mondo tutto intero
e concludo
passando il testimone da emma questa mia
lunga di prima di cinque anni fa ad
alice alice è una bambina che in classe
come da due anni da due anni da due mesi
sposate mi è una bimba di sei anni
perché ho ripreso
ripartita conj con i piccolini bambina
di sei anni non vedente
quasi non vedente ne dimostra 4 è
piccolina e della persona più curiosa
che abbia mai conosciuto nella mia vita
è la persona stranamente estremamente
curiosa ma ci vede pochissimo e di me
riconosce
più la voce ma si deve avvicinare
proprio tanto da vicino per riuscire a
vedere il mio viso e l'altro giorno l'ho
incontrata
fuori quindi non a scuola per i suoi
genitori mi sono avvicinata a lei mi
sono accovacciata per parlarle per
salutarla i suoi genitori le hanno
chiesto se
ricordasse il mio nome e alice ha
risposto
lei e la maestra sonia la maestra del
cerchio
l'immagine per voi è scomparsa eccola e
la maestra del cerchio
io passo con i bambini moltissimo tempo
la gran parte del mio tempo a scuola è
un tempo in cerchio per tutti i motivi
che vi ho detto
fino ad adesso perché credo che in quel
tipo di schema non schema ma in quel
tipo di situazione sia possibile
effettivamente imparare e costruirsi e
penso che alice
individuando mi come la maestra del
cerchio mi ha fatto il più grande
complimento
che io potessi desiderare e che auguro
anche a voi
[Applauso]